[Music]
okay free whenever you're ready I'll
help you and squeeze you and kiss you
and put coins in your eyes that's why we
don't be kids make dough for Elmo I am
guru Akash welcome to the city of
Atlantis Angelica you know that you're
mean to those babies and I've had enough
I will not let you bother them again
works for me
[Music]
this is Cree summer and her voice it's
kind of legendary I am best known for
being penny from Inspector Gadget
but when brainy look suspicious
Inspector Gadget are you all right Susie
Carmichael who really stood up the end
I'm Angelica and took care of those
babies and I play em now was Randy royal
princess Kida from the lost city of
Atlantis
Loki go now there you go there's the
taster so my great is it I knew you
uncle gadget would never rob a bank
let's say I started voice acting when I
was 11 years old my father Don Frank's
was the voice of sabertooths from the
x-men he also had the very first person
to ever voice in vogue effect from Star
Wars which is such a cool ass thing and
he had already been cast on Inspector
Gadget and he asked if they would be
kind enough to read to his daughter and
they said sure we'll give her a shot and
it literally took off like wildfire from
there hi my name's Susie what's yours I
know / Susie one of the most important
things was that she sound smart and that
she's very well spoken because there
were not a lot of brown girls in
cartoons
as a matter of fact they're still
learned beyond all this Cree is unique
for another reason
historically white voice actors
generally did the voices for cartoon
characters of all races trees thrive in
space that has often overlooked people
who look like boys I just put on some
bob balls I mean let's face it I'd do
the voices of all the brown girls and
all the animated Brown girls I still
ain't that many because there's this
really crazy belief that black girls
don't lords cartoons and then we don't
collect comics and then we don't like
sci-fi and that's the ass man we love it
I love when people of color come up to
me and say you don't know what it meant
to me to see myself in a cartoon I got
one little black girl that I get to see
that looks like me thank you so much I
get on fun okay there's this amazing
picture of my coworker it's him reading
a Ninja Turtles book lying next to a
super soaker when the super soaker came
out it was a game changer the slogan
wetter is better was essentially a
mantra for kids during summer break so
when I went to Atlanta to interview the
guy responsible for all that I had to
show him the photo Lonnie Johnson
invented the super soaker back in 1982
but that is not his only invention well
I have over a hundred patents
everything from the nerf gun to a
thermoelectric energy converter he also
worked on NASA's Galileo mission to
Jupiter and alongside the US military
the first Super Soaker actually I made
in my shop in my basement in the
evenings when I would come home from
work and at the time I was actually
working with a stealth bomber program
back when it was highly classified and I
actually couldn't even tell my wife but
I was working on during the daytime it
was that that top-secret the original
name for the Super Soaker was the drench
er we ran into a challenge regarding the
name because another inventor claimed
until we changed the name that Super
Soaker just to avoid having to deal with
that Super Soaker is definitely a way
better name when he started Lani wasn't
trying to create a toy for kids I was
working on a new type of heat pump that
would use water as a working fluid
instead of freon and I was experimenting
with signals that I had machined and I
shot a stream of water across the
bathroom and that policies maybe I
should put this hard science stuff aside
and work on something fun like a water
gun
it still works and this brings me back
to a previous point Lonnie Johnson is a
super genius scientist this is his lab
and this is what he's working on now
yeah right now I'm working on advanced
battery technology my goal is to develop
a battery that will store about three
times the energy of a lithium-ion
battery in comparison the Super Soaker
might not seem as hard science but it
was still a really really important
invention
[Music]
nearly everyone remembers mr. Rogers
neighborhood but not everyone knows that
this cardigan clad king of children's TV
Fred Rogers was actually a pioneer who
challenged racial stereotypes and media
enter Francois Clemens Francois
Scarborough Clemens and his role is
officer Clemens made him one of the
first recurring black characters on a
children's TV show when I started there
were two three shows period on
television that employed a black
character
Francois grew up during the civil rights
movement and times of great racial
tension in the u.s. so and Fred asked me
to be a police officer Fred are you sure
do you know what policemen represent in
the community where I was raised and
then he started talking about children
needing helpers and the positive
influence that I could have for young
children my heart opened as I listened
to him he accepted the role not knowing
he would end up playing officer Clemens
for 30 years and one of his most
memorable scenes is also one of his
favorites it's a very big deal for me to
be putting my feet in the water with
Fred during a time of segregation the
symbolism wasn't lost on Francois to say
that he didn't know what he was doing or
that he accidentally stumbled into
integration or talking about racism or
sexism that's not mr. Rogers it was well
planned and well thought out and I think
it was very impactful to say I love you
that impact was felt by many before
Francois it was personal I was in the
studio one day that particular day he
was filming the end of the show and when
he got to the part he said you make
every day a special day
you know how by just your being you and
I swear it was like he's looking right
into my eyes and when the music stopped
I said Fred were you talking to me and
he said yes I have been talking to you
for the years but you heard me today
[Music]
the dismal swamp is an environment that
has hazardous conditions associated with
it the heat you got poisonous snakes and
mosquitoes come out at certain times of
the year and it's unbearable but when
you think about some of the torture the
enslaved people's endured
I think if most of us were living during
that day and we had an option to go in
the swamp and live freely I think a lot
of us would take that option
[Music]
from the 17th century until the Civil
War escaped slaves known as Marines
found refuge in the Great Dismal Swamp
located on the border of Virginia and
North Carolina the swamp was wild and
inhospitable nevertheless it was there
that Runaways created self-sufficient
communities almost entirely cut off from
the outside world for the past 10 years
archaeologist Dan sayers from American
University has been studying these
settlements part of what I did was
develop this sort of research program
called the Great Dismal Swamp landscape
study most of my focus has been on
archaeological discovery of sites out in
the swamp as well as historical research
and then of course trying to understand
it before we start our research there
was a sense people lived in the swamp
for a variety of reasons but we really
wanted to go in the swamp and find
remnants of their lives out there and
sure enough we've been able to look at
several sites associate several of these
different groups probably in 1792 18 to
25 or 30 nail we found resistance I'm
sure the population they went up and
down though very strong potential for
any given moment for thousands of people
that they went out of the Great Dismal
inform these multi-generational
communities it was a radical form of
resistance in a good way
The Runaways was game sleary missed
everything to be free even if it meant
living in the harsh environment of the
swamp one former slave who briefly lived
in the swamp was a man named Moses
grandi I've done family genealogy
research in which I've uncovered a slave
narrative by Moses grandi who I believe
is my great-great grandfather's uncle
this Edmond granted my great-great
grandfather's headstone who was born in
1827 he was a Waterman and a Boltzmann
on the dismal swamp canal which was
being hand dug and he describes very
vividly in the slave narrative how they
were treated what they endured how they
were tortured if you had that kind of
experience and you had an opportunity to
come out to the swamp and live freely
under you know challenging conditions
you're gonna have a hard time getting
them out of there
the idea of Africans setting up
communities and being in in charge of
their destiny in the swamp I don't want
people to ever forget this history
you
[Music]